you've got to address this we have
been able to hold ourselves above the
stereotype
and in five minutes
she took it away
monique this i feel like this is a
season for you
how are you feeling about season five oh
my goodness
it's it's definitely stressful but
you know i was built for it
i'm a survivor i'm a strong person i can
handle the pressure
and you see it's a challenge just fly by
he's back he flies all over the house he
has posts
in every darn near corner he's showing
off right now
usually he's pretty quiet he says i know
the camera is on
i think he wants to be a part of the
interview do you want me to bring him in
yeah go get him let me get him because
he is showing off today
say hello to bryce there he is there he
is oh my gosh
that's my baby i had never seen a bird
on a leash monique i have to be honest
well i'm glad he's he's joined us for
the chat
too funny let's get back to potomac okay
would you say this is the hardest season
you've had on the show
absolutely absolutely um hitting from
all angles it's been really difficult
i have been mainly focused on the
incident itself
which was the altercation between myself
and candace and then the journey
afterward
going through therapy and lo and behold
i kept getting asked about charisse and
these rumors
and candace and how everything came
together
in giselle and everything else okay so
we're gonna spill the tea let's just
tell it all
the word on the street is monique and
her trainer brought a wee bit
too close for comfort and charisse has
tall people it's disgusting
and you know i'm just doing my best to
just stay strong and to
just tell my story and keep moving
forward safe to say
you felt under attack this whole season
more than ever more than ever really
feels like a full out attack
you know and it's never okay to attack
come and attack me
whatever but to try to attack my family
and my
child is disgusting and it's really
pathetic
seeing episode two is that what inspired
what i am calling
the instagram live to end all instagram
lives it was supposed to be an ambush
yeah it was they so this whole plan i
was never supposed to find out about
this
this was supposed to have went down like
a long time ago
you know honestly oh chris is he's
always wandering around back
we'll say hi baby
i know you you all up in the interview
um no actually when we saw episode 2
we were just like wow but i didn't feel
a need to address it i was just going to
be like you know what whatever they can
say whatever they want this is
a show that is driven off of rumors so
whatever y'all can have that
it wasn't until candace went live and
said my child's name
that i said you know what now i'm gonna
tell everybody everything
there was a conversation about
someone plotting to
[Music]
spread a rumor that
chase was not chris's baby the rumor was
going to be
that it wasn't
chris's baby it was a trainer's baby and
i said
that maybe look just like chris that
chris samuel spat that baby out
there's no way that
no anyone is going to believe that this
is not
chris's baby i mean you get in here too
because you said you told everybody
everything too mister
you know once my child came up i was
literally
to the third power of angry and upset
and i was just so floored and so upset
about bringing a child in and hearing
about this nasty plot and rumor
just to take my wife down i'm the man in
this house and the first instinct is to
protect your family
and to see my wife's character you know
get slandered on tv
to see my child brought into it i mean
this is below
the belt lowest of the low i'm
heartbroken i'm upset i'm angry i'm the
one up at night she's sleeping like a
baby and i'm jealous
so i mean that's where i stand on that
in that instagram live
you he just hijacked my interview
in that instagram live you did you have
a pile of receipts
of kind of this plot against you so what
it was is this all started two years ago
so this particular person who was
creating this whole mess
started reaching out to my friends and
producers
and cast so what i did back then i
started
gathering all of my receipts i started
asking them to give me statements as to
what conversations they had
with that person and i held on to
everything just in case i needed to get
legal
and uh go after her for defamatory
remarks
and you know so i made sure i had
everything ready
and this friend has never been a cast
member this is somebody you knew
before the show right this is not
somebody that the audience is super
familiar with
they're familiar because they've seen
this person on the show season two
right so uh the one thing that stood out
to me
uh when i first told this friend that i
was going to be doing the show
her response was i knew you would always
be the one to make me famous
and i should have went with my instinct
then because something hit me when she
said that and i was like
that's a little weird no congratulations
no no that was a little weird
and then this person went and looped
charisse into this mess it seems
yes she caught candace candace talked to
her talked to her for two hours
and then she forwarded or exchanged
numbers
with her and then charisse and then it
just took off from there
do you think charisse took the bait
because she wants back on the show
absolutely absolutely charisse is that
person where she'll feed you a bunch of
stuff
and she'll try to get other people to do
her bidding so that she can always
remain
and look innocent i know how she works
so
i'm not i'm not falling for it i did not
know that you all had that much beat
we'll talk later what did you make of
candace saying she didn't know that you
and charisse had this whole history this
drama when candace was around
in season three when things really fell
apart candace knew exactly what was
going on
and when she made that statement you'll
you'll see in my expression
and i said screw it i'm not playing this
game
and i called her out every step of the
way after that you said
on that instagram live that the plot
about
your family the initial intention was to
be brought up at the season four reunion
do you know why that didn't come up at
the reunion like candace said in her
life
they probably backed away from it
because of the fact that they knew
it was that nasty and they knew that it
was unbelievable
i guess they knew that okay this isn't
gonna fly and they had to go back to the
drawing board
at the end of the day who do you blame
for this
mess i blame myself for having a friend
who would think that it'd be in her best
interest to completely try to ruin a
person who she's known for 14 years and
i blame myself for bringing her
into my home around my family and even
on the show
you know so at the end of the day i'll
take it
and i'll say it's all on me for not
being smart enough to see through the bs
from a person who called myself
her best friend and and vice versa i
thought it was interesting in the live
you said
the altercation with candace has nothing
to do
with the rumor mill situation that's
going on in these first few episodes
can you give me any tease of what does
lead to that moment
i can tease it this way watch every past
season of candace
and then watch all of the tweets and the
vulgar tweets that she's ever put out
and then you can draw your own
conclusion as to why that happened
candace has accused you of lying or
misrepresenting what happens in that
altercation
in this kind of press cycle we're in for
the beginning of the season what is your
response to her
saying that you're lying and
misrepresenting what happened
um first of all i haven't even spoken on
it
and second candace is exposing
who she is as a liar and a manipulator
every day
so all people got to do is just not only
watch the show
but watch her social media and they will
be able to put everything together
for themselves and they will be able to
see who's really the liar
well her past social media came back to
bite her yesterday
some people found um some old homophobic
tweets that she then had to apologize
for
yes i saw a lot of people tagging me and
my dms were filled up with can you
address this can you
what is going on and i wanted to stay
far away from it honestly
i don't i'm not falling for the bs she
is showing you who
she is every day one tweet at a time
you mentioned at the top of this chat
that you've been focused on what
happened
after the altercation and the journey
you went on karen told me that she
advised you to
take the time you needed to figure out
what you needed to do to move forward
absolutely and that wasn't anything that
someone had to tell me that was
something i came to on my own
and that's why i asked the women to meet
me at karen's house that day
so you'll see as the season unfolds i
took this very seriously
i didn't want a pity party i didn't need
any of that i wanted to
figure out what triggered me why it
triggered me
and what can i do to make sure that this
never happens again
so that is what my goal was and i feel
as though i definitely achieved that
so you called to come to jesus meeting
yes
okay that's an interesting twist because
i i think people would assume that maybe
karen
or giselle was like we have to talk
about this but you're the one who said
no we have to talk about this i wanted
to talk about it i'm 100
woman with a with a beautiful brain and
it works very well
i don't need anyone's assistance
did you in this thought process think
you know what i gotta walk away from
this show
oh yeah definitely that that thought
actually came about and it it went even
further than just being a thought i'll
just put it like that
but i ultimately decided that as long as
i could feel comfortable with continuing
uh my filming and to show my journey
as long as that was in a comfortable
environment for myself
then that's what i wanted to do and
that's what i ended up deciding to do
and now that i know what i know now i'm
very grateful that i didn't walk away
that i stuck it out
at the beginning of the season you
dropped
[Music]
does that song have a have a message for
your co-stars
so i will say this that throw little
digs at
a person or two
no competition eat them up dinner dinner
you wanna come against me i'm gonna win
a winner
you gotta the lyric video we get the
umbrella
so there's all the references for
everything that's ever happened on the
show are in there
exactly exactly and that's pretty much
what it was a culmination of
my time here what i believe why i do
things i do what i believe and stand up
for
and i said this is going to be an anthem
if not for everyone else it will be for
me
all right we gotta wrap things up here
the rest of the season there's obviously
a lot left to watch
what do you want fans to know about
what's still to come
i want fans to know that out of all the
seasons i really
feel that this season is the season that
people can relate to just as being a
human being
they will be able to look at the season
and say okay if i put myself in that
position
how would i react and they're gonna see
exactly
what a normal person would react to but
what they're also going to see is
how you're able to come back and recover
and regroup
and really deal with things they're
going to see vulnerability
they're going to see a lot of good human
moments
and hopefully it's a teaching moment for
uh myself
and others and um i'm just excited to
see how everything unfolds
well i am excited too
[Music]
you